[Musique]
bonsoir mon propre aux longs jupons
à l'opérateur je suis dingue au pont de
vaux rupture
et moi je ferais semble endormi je
regarderai juliette à prendre son bain
hop hop hop hop hop on bon froid ou mais
c'est une salle de bain
[Musique]
mais pourquoi ne fait-elle pas comme
tout le monde part qu elle se baigne au
clair de lune dans les rayons de la lune
oui elle prend des bagues lune ce
qu'elle est amusant ya bien des gens qui
prennent de bonnes semaines juliette à
elle prend des vins de lune c'est
justement ce soir la lune et rabat bien
sûr c'est la pleine lune gillier pts 1
ta salle de bal trek tiens je te mets
aussi une savane est non les boues
n'aime pas ah bon tu vois elle va
prendre un bain d'huile sur son perchoir
comme ça sans électricité la fenêtre
grande ouverte
et après elle se baignera oui et puis
elle se grattera donne ça au delà de
plus ou alors c'est vous et après elle
jouera avec des cailloux ce que ça va
être mignon dès qu'on tente de ménager
l'iata
et ce après oui mais julietta elle
trouve à manger tout seul
bon maintenant il faut éteindre la
lumière et ouvre la fenêtre replan moi
je vous dis produit et je le sais que
moi je vais vous prendre son pain
tu l'emmènes pas fait promener d'abord
ce soir je n'ai pas le dos à toute
petite promenade pour me faire plaisir
tous
ou tu vois l envie de prendre l'air
avant de faire cette voile est
[Musique]
diffèrent
en l'on vient julien ah
mais vous des enfants tout de suite ou
lui d'accord d'accord à de manus et bad
brains
[Musique]
oh ce nounours que fait-il
tiens
julietta bonsoir ma belle que l'
aventure patron cette juliette part j'ai
perdu or lords mais nous nous elle est
ici au
l'autre qu'une elle m'a fait courir à
lons julietta va vite retrouver
cornichons bonne nuit
en route à demain des enfants faute de
bord
[Musique]
oh